And it's so readable with camel case.
No, it's way more readable with underscores.
You're so used to reading with spaces.
But, but it's, I'm a Python bro.
And we got to name all of our functions with underscores.
Don't freaking tell me you're a Python bro.
I am a Python bro.
Best math of hacking when you can just, you know, critical thing, right?
All right, guys, you know, the drill, this is the segment of the show where we typically
do an ad, but today we got something different for you.
And it's an exciting announcement that we are launching the critical thinking pen test
group.
Um, we have an amazingly talented group of hackers that live in the CTBB discord and in
the community, um, that we're so grateful to be able to work with.
And we have a specific particular niche of that called the full-time hunters guild.
Um, these are people that are validated to have performed very high level in bug bounty.
Um, and we are going to be performing pen tests, uh, for you, the listener, if you guys have
scope that you want to be tested, um, ourselves, meaning me rezo, regret me, uh, other members
of the CTBB team and pulling highly qualified members that are aligned with your scope specifically
from the full-time hunters guild to also do, uh, penetration testing as required.
Um, so we're going to make sure with all the hackers that we have access to that the hackers
that are working on your scope are extremely qualified in exactly what you would like to
have tested.
Right.
Cause we're pulling from a big group of people.
Um, so if you're interested in that and you think your organization could benefit from
that, check out pen test.ctbb.show.
It's going to be a lot of fun.
We're going to tear stuff up.
It's going to be amazing.
Um, so yeah, drop us a line if you're interested.
Um, and then the second piece here is of course, I want to remind you, we do have the full-time
hunters guild available.
So if you are a hunter that is out there and is killing it and wants to be among other high-performing
hunters, this is the place to do it.
Okay.
ctbb.show slash FTHG for full-time hunters guild.
Go ahead and apply.
If you meet the criteria, um, and you'll get access to not only a high caliber community,
but also opportunities like the pen tests, uh, opportunities that we have coming through
critical thinking.
So lots of exciting stuff going on.
Um, excited to work with you guys.
If you think you could benefit from some pen tests or if you want to join the full-time
hunters guild community.
All right.
I'll see you there.
Peace.
Sup hackers got the this week in bug bounty segment for you before we hop into the episode.
Um, the first item on the list today is a article by yes, we hack entitled cost AI frontier
models and more a measure take on the future of security testing.
And as we've been talking a ton on the pod recently about, you know, what is the future
of bug bounty?
What is the future of a continuous security testing as we know it?
There are a lot of takes and there are a lot of different opinions floating around.
So I think it's really important to get a bunch of different perspectives.
So, uh, I'd recommend you go ahead and read this article, um, and get a little bit more
data, uh, in, and we've also got another article from, uh, integrity, uh, that we'll link in the
description as well called common AI misconceptions debugged.
Okay.
Um, and this is also sort of talking about the way that AI is affecting the industry.
So two really good articles, one from yes, we hack one from integrity on it.
Um, a quick takeaway that I had from the integrity one was this right here, which is, um, uh, validity
ratios remain constant, even though the volume has been increased dramatically, uh, across bug bounty at this point.
Right from 2022 to 2025 submissions grew 328%.
Um, and we're going to see that I'm sure even more of this year, um, with, with, uh, AI becoming more prolific.
So, um, but that does mean a lot of more valid reports too.
So we're just getting a lot of volume.
Um, and we've got to figure out how to, how to sort it out.
Um, so those are some articles for you to take a look at, uh, last but not least, we have a bounty sync plus social event, uh, that is being held by integrity in, uh, the UK and London.
That's Thursday, May 21st.
We're going to link that, uh, down below, but that seems like a good opportunity to connect with people in the London area, um, in the, in the bug bounty world.
So if you're in the UK, uh, definitely check this out.
If you're near London and can make it over for this event Thursday, May 21st, um, in London.
Uh, all right.
I think that's it for the twib.
Let's go to the show.
Dude.
So I step away for one week and you put out a doomer episode, bro.
Listen, I did an awesome, I did an awesome ad read.
I made a custom thumbnail.
I carried a good episode.
Thank you.
You're right though.
It was a little bit of a doomer episode.
It was a little bit of a doomer episode, man.
Um, and I feel you, I feel you.
It is concerning.
I'm not going to lie.
The, the landscape is concerning right now.
Hey, I know you probably want to jump to other stuff, but it's on the, I'm actually going to do it right now.
I'm going to share my screen here.
All right.
I made a, cause since we're talking about the last episode, I made a image to represent what I was talking about.
Oh my gosh, dude.
What is this?
I really think that this funnel, why bug bounty is dying.
What the heck?
This is a bug bounty podcast.
Yeah, I know.
But anyways, listen, the point is, this is what people need to be concerned about.
And it's what they need to push again.
This is why they need to adapt and evolve and go deeper and incorporate AI into their hacking.
But, uh, yeah, I feel like the, I kind of explained it well, but the point I was trying to get across was this basically, right?
Is that AI written codes probably going to get better.
There's going to be AI code review, internal hackbot testing filters more.
And then when you get down here, you got to compete with the sharks with the likes of me.
And so, yeah, exactly.
So yeah.
Anyways, the, the super powered shark, the shark on steroids, because we're using cloud as well.
Right.
Um, so yeah, no, I, I do agree with you, but on the flip side of that, you know, they have, we also have non software engineers pushing code to production because you can just will, will an app into existence now.
Yep.
And Lord knows that, you know, the dev ops people or, you know, whatever are going to also have some problems with how these things are pushed to prod.
Yeah.
So, um, yeah, I think, I think there will be plenty of stuff to go around at least for the next five years, but it's definitely going to be, it's definitely moving faster than I anticipated before.
So.
And like you said, there's so much counter pressure.
It's like, there's, there's like pressure to get out code way faster.
There's way more code going out the door.
There's non technical people writing so much code that there's no way the technical code people can actually review it.
And so, yeah.
Yeah.
And, and I think we just don't understand the code at a depthful level as much anymore.
Right?
Like I, I don't even know, I wrote an app yesterday and the day before, um, and which I'll talk about eventually on the pod, but I wrote it.
I have no idea what API functions are in this thing.
Right.
Not, not even a single clue.
I've never even looked at the code.
I literally just talked to Claude and it's beautiful and it works exactly how I want it to work and it's nuanced and it's lovely.
But I have no idea how it works.
You know?
So yeah, that's scary.
And that's why you need some buck hunters to test that out for you, Justin.
Yeah, seriously, seriously.
Um, okay.
Um, so, okay.
Before we jump into the actual, um, meat for this episode, I got a little confession, man, because I've gone in the pod and I flexed and I've said, your boy is above burnout is essentially what I've said.
I last time on the pod, like burnout that's for those newer full-time hunters, right?
You know, um, got a little burned out, man.
I got a little burned out.
I mean, it only took three back to back events is all it took.
Three back to back events overlapping.
And I don't know, man, fricking Matthias Carlson, man.
He goes hard.
That fricker goes hard when he's in a live hacking event, you know?
And so you felt like the need to keep up.
I felt the need to keep up, you know?
And, and so I started putting in these crazy hours.
I got kids.
He doesn't have kids.
Screw you Matthias for not having kids.
Um, and, and so it's like, you know, I just can't, can't get the same volume of hours while still being a present parent, you know, that I used to be able to.
So I was like sacrificing the sleep and then Korea hits and I get all these crazy bugs and I'm jet lagged as Frick.
And then I come back and I'm like, okay, you know, such an awesome time.
And then why am I not wanting to create content?
Why am I not wanting to hack?
Why do I just want to lay here?
You know?
Dude, it's real.
I don't know about it.
And I think it's not just burnout.
Like it's also probably the fact that you're, you're doing incredible this year on top of that.
You don't have some like ridiculously large financial need.
Pushing you to go find those bugs.
Cause you're also doing well.
So it's kind of like on both ends.
It is, it is a little bit on both, but I feel like, you know, I feel like I've had so much fun hacking these past like couple of weeks.
And then all of a sudden, boom, like, why is the passion not there?
You know?
And then, and then, you know, just needed a little time.
It just needed a little time to come back and it's back.
It's back.
Good.
All right.
Um, I got a bunch of stuff.
You got a bunch of stuff.
You want to go first or should I?
Uh, I feel like, yeah, I already went first.
With that image.
So you got to go now.
Oh, okay.
All right.
I'm up next.
You stole this one.
You stole this one for me, by the way, it was going to be on my list.
And then I get in here and it's already here.
And I'm like, Oh, come on.
All right.
Well, I'm going to explain some really, uh, crazy shit on this.
So, uh, you know, if you want to add to it, you can, but I'm, I'm going deep in the crypto bin here.
Perfect.
So I'm going to talk more about the Ampscript.
So, okay.
Well here, why don't you start us off with the Ampscript and then I'll go talk about the, um, the, the crypto stuff.
Yeah, sure.
So, um, basically.
Uh, Ampscript is a custom language.
Basically it's like, uh, so first let's, let's intro it.
This is Searchlight Cyber's write up on, uh, the ghosts of encryption pass, how we read all your emails in Salesforce Marketing Cloud.
So this is a story of how they pwned Salesforce Marketing Cloud through Ampscript, some crypto stuff, all that altogether.
Right?
Yep.
Okay.
All right.
Go, go with the Ampscript.
Uh, I, I've not like, since this was on yours, I didn't end up prepping it, but no, no, no, no, no.
I'm still going to talk about this.
Cause I think it's really cool.
So one basically Ampscript is like server side template language.
That's, that's mostly what you need to know that is specific to SFDC, um, Salesforce and specifically to their marketing cloud.
And, uh, I mentioned a vulnerability, oh man, like maybe a year ago that me and Evan Conley and Chubbs found, which used, uh, one of the things in this blog post.
So if you scroll down to under foot gun, number one, treat as content.
Yeah.
So there's this really cool treat as content, which basically means, Hey, evaluate this.
And then you can also do, uh, HTTP get.
So we hosted more Ampscript on Chubbs' server.
And then, and then input for our 50 character payload treat as content, HTTP, get his URL.
So then it would basically pull his, it would pull more Ampscript from his server and put it inside of that treat as content.
So if you're ever limited in a Ampscript injection insertion point, you can use that, that back to back.
Nice.
Okay.
So you kind of, um, incurred a double evaluation scenario.
Exactly.
That's exactly what we did.
You had a template injection.
Yes.
And then, or, and then you, you needed to get, you know, more character space.
And so you hit an HTTP get, and then took the output of that, dumped it into treat as content and invoked another template injection.
That's exactly right.
That's sick, dude.
Yeah.
That's why I tweeted about it.
Cause it was so cool.
I should have, I should have broken it down, like in a whole bunch of tweets, but actually let me see if I can share it.
I can.
You can track it down.
Essentially the, the, the, um, the full flow here, just to give the listeners, you know, knowledge about the article is this is how they pwned Salesforce marketing cloud.
They found a, uh, template injection in the subject line of emails, uh, because of double evaluation.
And it's using this weird amp script method, uh, of templates, which is percent, percent equals, or the lesser known version, which is, um, curly bracket, curly bracket equals.
And that triggers the amp script.
So make sure we're adding these to our template injection payloads.
Right.
Um, and then, you know, using this template injection, they're able to do some crazy crypto stuff, which I'll explain later.
You know, and, and it's a tangential part of the scope, but it does come back to the template injection.
Um, and yeah, really get access to a bunch of the data in the system.
Um, that's the full flow of this.
And what I want to talk to you guys, uh, about in just a sec is this, uh, crypto attack that they did later on in the article.
Um, did you have.
I'll show this super quick and then I'll switch back to you.
Okay.
So it's funny.
Cause like, obviously marketing cloud is all about marketing, so it's not in the title, but this was in the first name.
And, uh, and so the funniest thing was basically getting an email with the exfiltration of all of the users in the database as, as your name.
So it's like, hi, Justin and Douglas and Joseph, and everyone, you know, it's like, it's like the email is like, like a hundred pages long in your Gmail.
And it's just a huge data leak.
But anyways, yeah, it was the first name field.
And then we put the extra Ampscripts, uh, stuff living on shove the server here.
And then it worked like this.
So anyways, I thought people would think that was cool.
Yeah.
Dude.
.gg is such a good, uh, domain.
It is.
It's cool, man.
I have a good one though.
I have a good one.
I can't speak it out loud, but I'm pretty proud of the one that I have.
Um, actually I'll tell you, Richard, just bleep it.
I've got.
.
Yeah.
That's pretty freaking great.
Right.
That's very cool.
Yeah.
Um, okay.
Um, so let's get back into this.
So, uh, first, you know, the, the, they get a template injection, um, via double evaluation in the subjects or titles of emails.
Um, and then they're essentially what they're trying to do is get a template injection.
Um, they realize that these emails are also, you know, available at a domain.
Right.
And so they look at, you know, they click on their like view and browser button or whatever.
And they look at the, the, um, resulting URL that comes from that.
And it has this, you know, QS parameter that seems to control where, you know, what email is displayed.
So it's got some encrypted values.
Right.
And they enumerated a bunch of these and they found out that there's three primary formats for this.
One of them is a, uh, JWT that looks pretty solid.
The next one is, is a, is a, you know, hex.
And then finally one they find later is just, you know, raw parameters.
Um, I didn't find that till later, I guess though.
Um, and my first point that I wanted to mention here was like, this is a really, you know, you're sniffing for blood.
Your spidey senses should be tingling here when you see this implementation change because probably somebody found something and, and they, you know, sort of fixed it, but they didn't backdate it.
Right.
Um, and a lot of times the pipes that glue all of these things together are the same.
So if they're leaving the old, you know, format in place, then you might be able to exploit that even with the newer format being present.
So very interesting.
And the way this often looks, cause I've, I've been a developer before.
Mm-hmm .
I feel like a lot of times whenever you need to support multiple formats, you'll say like, if it's encoded, decode it, else treat it as it is.
Exactly.
And so honestly, I think, I thought what you were going to say is as you approach that, that, um, that lesson there, I think the lesson is often you should try other formats in parameters, like just across bug bounty in general, across app sec testing.
You know, it's kind of the same thing behind like, oh, if a JSON post request works, you should try other formats.
Like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like
you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you know, like, you
article, which is just lovely. And the days of that unfortunately, are, you know, few because, like, they've got, you know, stack, stack exchange, the number of questions and answers has just like tanked. Yeah, because of AI. But anyway, this is the, you know, the format that they have. And knowing that they start sort of doing some bit flipping on the QS parameter, which is what I've said on the pod many times,
is like, don't shy away from these crypto bugs. People implement stuff poorly all the time. And in unauthenticated CBC algorithm, guys, you do bit flipping. And as long as it doesn't cause light, just flip a couple things here and there. And sometimes you'll see it actually passes through. And then the result of the decrypted, you know, piece, which is in the response, will just look corrupted like this right here. For those of you on YouTube, right, it'll just look like a, you know, question mark or, you know, a different character or something.
Like that, right. And that means that they're using an unauthenticated CBC, you know, algorithm. Okay. And so anyway, take away there, do bit flipping when you see encrypted stuff. Okay, because you found I found a lot of padding oracles. And I found a lot of bugs just from doing that. Okay.
Yeah.
So the really crazy thing about this exploit that I didn't, I did not know, and this could just be me not knowing, you know, about this exploit, or it could be that they came up with this, is that they figured out a way to get the IV for the CBC by doing this really cool technique. Okay. And I'm not gonna lie. Typically, nowadays, I just read something, you know, in the articles, and I have no problem coming on the pod and talking about it.
Yeah, I did rehearse the segment. Because it is it is hard to talk about, like crypto stuff in the audio medium. And without a visual, you know, representation, right? Yeah, I'm gonna do my best. I'm not sure how it's gonna go.
I'm gonna close my eyes and test you. I'm not gonna read their article or like, I'm just gonna close my eyes and listen to just your audio.
Well, okay, that's great. And and I would also recommend for anybody that wants to understand this better, take this whole article and put it into Gemini. And then just ask it questions until you understand. Okay. Because that's what I did before to refresh my memory on this and it and it's lovely. So what they actually did here, the way CBC works, is that there's an IV initialization vector that gets
used with CBC. And that is what is xord with the ciphertext of the first block. And so and that produces, you know, the output. So what what we they did here in order to get that IV so that they could decrypt the rest of it. So I want you guys to think of it like this, the decryption algorithm is, you know, a function D. And inside of that is ciphertext block one, right?
And then the output of that function gets xord with the IV. Okay, so D. Of the ciphertext one.
xord with IV. Okay, so what they did was they padded out the first part of their ciphertext with eight null bytes. Okay, so that C, that C one, which would be the first block that gets passed into the decryption algorithm, it becomes all null bytes.
all null bytes. Okay. And so the when it gets passed into the decryption algorithm, the output of that is just going to be junk. And that gets on that.
So is it predictable junk? No, it's just junk. Okay, and that gets xord with the IV. Okay, so now your junk that comes from the null bytes tanks the IV for you, right? And then the way that the second block is, is, you know, built out is it takes the second block, which was our original first block. And it passes that through the decryption function and it xord
xord is it, it xord is it with the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is
the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext, which is the ciphertext
So you do this with over a bunch of different valid IDs, and you know a little bit about the plaintext from the Stack Overflow article, right?
And you brute force each bit of the IV until it matches the pattern, the output matches the pattern that you know that the actual plaintext has.
Yeah.
Okay.
And then over the course of a bunch of IDs, you are able to narrow down and extract the IV.
And then using that IV, you can decrypt the first block originally and get the raw text out.
That's awesome.
So it is awesome what they did here.
I think that came across decently.
I don't know.
Maybe you can tell me.
No, no, no.
No, I think it came across fine.
The question is, were they smart enough to know that or did they just use AI to do that?
I don't know, man.
You know, they're also using Padre, which is a, you know, system for doing these padding oracle slash CPC related
attacks.
So that's cool.
And also shout out to Padre.
I've used it a couple of times.
Really useful.
Very extensible.
Love that about it.
And the other key thing that I want you guys to take away here, one, that 8-byte nullbyte trick is
amazing.
Two, is that definitely, you know, make sure you're using Padre for these sort of things.
And three, you need to make sure you know the format of the, you know, something about the plaintext
version of the value you're supposed to be extracting, right?
Because that allows you to sanity check your IV checks.
And then you can see that.
Anyways, my whole point of this is that the main point, which is which is like really the the the low hanging fruit that I think everyone in the audience should check is their description front matter field.
So ask skills in Markdown.
There's the thing called front matter at the top.
Right.
It's like the the title, the description, like references or author or something.
So the description field, at least in cloud code, and I think also in codex is what gets passed to the agent, assuming that you're, you know, your main prompt isn't so long that it gets truncated.
Anyways, the description field there is what actually gets sent to the agent.
So that's all it has.
It has the title and the description to decide when to invoke.
Right.
That description field in Markdown is not a multi line.
And so if you have description colon and then new line and then you have some descriptions or you have description colon the first line and then you go down to new lines, all of those extra lines are not getting picked up because Markdown does not do multi line by default.
You have to.
And so this is what it fixed on a ton of ours.
So.
So here's what you want.
Here's what everyone wants.
You want.
Oh, you want the description colon and then greater than dash.
After that, it'll it'll pick up every single line.
It'll massively impact included.
Let me actually, I'm just going to do a new doc and show everyone I'm talking about just super quick for anyone watching on line.
Yeah, dude, that's crazy though, because that means like half of your description, you know, everything but the first line of your description might not be making it into Claude.
Right.
Which means it may not be triggering these whenever you, you need them to be right.
So let's say you have a, I have a skill called reso skill.
Right.
And the description here is like this, you know, normally I would say like, I want you to invoke when you say.
You see a 403, right?
The next.
The only thing that was going to the agent was this.
Oh my gosh.
And I think in a bunch of mine, I had something like this.
And I thought that this, and for the listeners, basically I had something that was like description colon just greater than.
And I think this does work in some markdown formats, but this does not work for the way Claude code works.
So you want it to be like this description colon greater than dash.
Yeah.
That's exactly what you want.
And that will, that will fix all.
It's a really weird format.
I've never seen it before.
That is what you want and it will fix all of your skill invocations.
Okay.
I also thought when you said greater than you probably meant less than no, he actually means greater than, greater than dash.
Description colon greater than dash.
Yep.
Yeah.
Okay.
So a couple of things here.
It also fixed for many of mine camel case into underscore case.
I don't know why, but I think that it got higher invocation rates with that.
So if your skill names or camel case, switch on the snake case and then.
I freaking hate that.
Why?
Cause I.
You're a camel case bro.
Yeah, dude.
Totally all day.
Oh, don't love me.
Snake cats are so much better.
It inflates the size of things and it's so readable with camel case.
No, it's way more readable with underscores.
You're so used to reading with spaces, but, but it's.
I'm a Python bro.
And we got to name all of our functions with underscores.
Don't freaking tell me you're a Python bro.
I am a Python bro.
Yeah, but I'm a snake case.
Back in the day, that was the standard and then they changed it.
Okay.
Well, listen here, at least tell me you're a two space Python bro and not a four space Python bro.
Get, get out, get out, get out.
You're, you are fired.
Do you actually use four spaces or do you use tabs?
Please tell me you're not tabs.
I use tabs.
I use tabs bro.
I use tabs and you're on windows and you're on.
I don't use anything now because I, I, I, this is, this is going to be,
maybe this is one of those situations where, you know, opposites attract, right?
Where we're.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Anyway, so you're saying somehow for some reason, Claude is wrong and bad.
And it wants you to use underscores.
Is that correct?
So skill names should be underscores or at least in my testing, it invokes better when you do that.
And the very last thing I was going to mention is some of my skills had the word Claude in them.
Apparently that is like a huge no, no.
So if you have, like I had a skill called DM other Claude's and I would allow my Claude locally to message my Claude on my VPS.
I changed it to DM other agents and all of a sudden it like massively improved.
I think that the word Claude is like a reserved word.
And so it either gets like parsed or, or doesn't view it as well or something.
Um, yeah, I, I didn't look into the nitty gritty details, but yeah.
Interesting.
That is, that is pretty cool.
Yeah.
Okay.
I, I'm just going to take a breather for a second, you know, from that, that massive disappointment that just, uh, you know, hit me.
Um, and I guess we'll talk about it's all right.
You know, watchtowers got me covered.
They're going to, they're going to, you know, get me focused on this next writeup.
Okay.
So, um, this next writeup is the internet is falling down, falling down, falling down.
Uh, and it is none other than the C panel off bypass, which is breaking everything.
So by the time this episode airs, you guys probably have already like digested all of this, but I did want to walk through a couple of the, um, beautiful pieces about this exploit.
Um, one it's Pearl.
Um, so, um, you know, when you're looking at the, um, the, you know, actual code here, it really helps a lot.
Right.
And, you know, sometimes we run into these situations where we're trying to reverse engineer something and it's like a binary and it's just such a pain.
Um, I will say like I've, I've hacked on a couple of things that are Pearl or, um, you know, Python, and it's just so much more fun.
Uh, that being said, I know for a fact, a lot of good hackers have looked at this and do it.
I've looked at this and not found this bug.
Yeah.
Um, so really cool that, um, you know, this vulnerability was discovered and it, this is, you know, watchtower reverse engineering it, um, reverse engineering patch.
Um, so here is the situation.
Um, they look at the patch, they figure out that they find this beautiful comment that says filter against slash r slash n, uh, from values before writing kills the CRLF injection primitive against the on disk key value record for the
format.
And that is the most in depth message I have ever seen in a batch in my entire life.
Um, like it almost gives it away.
Yeah, totally.
Like really, I mean, not, not totally gives it away, but I mean, it gives you put one right to the meat, you know, like the primitive that you need.
So the situation here was that, um, part of the off material was being parsed and then written in the, um, file system to a file.
And guys, I just freaking love this.
Let me see if I can find the file, uh, right here.
Right.
Um, var cpanel sessions raw and then the session ID.
And I just love this shit guys.
This is exactly what I'm talking about.
Like you, you, we've got to thoroughly assess these systems and, and understand how the full off flow works, right?
Is it actually writing files to disk, you know, with, with your authentication material.
And in this scenario, it really is.
And that should just be putting me, me, me, me, me, me, you know, in your head when you see something like that.
Uh, and the way that they had to make this exploit work was, uh, they actually used two different authentication methods, one from a cookie and one from an off header.
So that's another really beautiful thing is like, look at different routes for authentication.
Long story short, by combining the cookie and the authentication header, they're able to smuggle a slash r slash n in and get that written to disk.
Uh, in this session descriptor file, which is slash r slash n delimited.
Okay.
So now they're injecting arbitrary attributes into a session.
Um, and they were able to establish a pre-auth session by submitting an invalid, um, you know, username and password.
Right.
Um, and so that was really cool.
Now they're injecting attributes into there, but they keep hitting these roadblocks.
And I just, I love the way Watchtower writes, dude.
They're like, you know, they're like, and that's, that's it.
Is this the big red button time?
You know, and then they're, they submit it and they're like, shit, you know, like what's going on?
Uh, why isn't this working?
Why are we always treated so badly is what they say.
Um, and then they hit another roadblock with their 403.
Um, and there's like a cached version of this, you know, slash r slash n delimited file that is loaded into JSON.
And the endpoints prefer the cached version.
So now they've got to find, you know, a primitive in the system that, uh, forces a reload from, from the raw file rather than the cache.
And then they finally find that and, and they make it work and then they keep going.
And then they, they run it again and they hit a 403 again.
Right.
And, um, so they just keep going and keep going and keep going.
And do we deserve this?
Yeah.
You'd think we were done at this point, you know, um, give us strength.
I love these articles, man.
Um, but, uh, anyway, as they continue down with the, the exploit, they figured it out.
They got the cache invalidated.
They inject, injected another, you know, value into the, um, file, which bypassed, uh, a, um, defense in depth measure where they did the password check again.
And finally they got the full off bypass.
Um, and I just think that's such an example of like force of will in these exploits, right?
Obviously if they're patching it, there's something that's been done here, but they are persevering, running into blockade after blockade after blockade and getting the full off bypass, which is just freaking inspiring.
Do you think there are lots of moments when companies trying to reverse patches, uh, end up finding tangential bugs because like, because like that first primitive was there and they got that easily, but then they got blocked.
And then they had to find another primitive that isn't exactly clear in the patch.
And then when they find one, it's like, Oh, is that actually a different route to the vulnerability?
Yeah.
And, you know, who knows what the actual threat actor was using or the original finder, you know?
Um, so very cool.
And actually sort of mentioning that, um, searchlight cyber also did a writeup, uh, on this off bypass and they released a cpanel, um, a high integrity, you know, high fidelity check, which is what they always do, which I freaking love them for.
Right.
Yeah.
Is they release these like really quick and easy little scripts.
You can point at a host and say, Hey, is the, is this vulnerable?
Right.
Yeah.
Awesome.
They're so cool for that.
Um, and they added two things to this one.
Um, they added, uh, the way, uh, a third way of accessing this, you know, there were two ways mentioned in the main article, but there's actually a third way through, um, a, another port that's open on cpanel.
Where you can hit this super weird reverse proxy rule and it, and it, um, hits one of the management ports, um, in the backend.
So there's actually, you can't just block off the management ports in the WHM service, uh, to, to patch this bug.
You have to also patch, uh, you know, block off, um, a third one.
I'm trying to figure out which one it is.
I don't have it right in front of me right now, but there's another service that you need to block off as well.
Um, and then finally, they also mentioned that, Hey, if you're checking for that invalid password to get the pre-auth session that I mentioned, if you're doing that on route every time it's going to lock everybody out.
Uh, so here's the.
Is it just crazy to me that they keep this stored on disk in anyways?
Like I just wouldn't assume this would always be in a database and like every app.
Yeah, dude.
I don't know.
I mean, that does give me legacy vibes.
I know PHP also does some stuff like this.
So maybe it's just a, you know, pearl PHP legacy thing.
Um, but yeah, I think it is a little whack and, um, and yeah, just wanted to shout out the, um, the SL cyber team there for releasing the scanner and also finding some really good, um, other mechanisms that don't cause lockout.
Uh, to confirm that the vulnerability exists on your target.
So we'll, we'll, uh, we'll link that in the description if you guys want to check that out as well.
Perfect.
So I, um, wanted to give just a little bit of feedback from the last episode.
Obviously I know we talked about it a little bit at the beginning.
Um, I've been doing like, uh, hacker advisory board for hacker one, and then also bug crowd just here recently, because I think they bring me in because of the AI knowledge and stuff.
And then they're just all struggling, right?
I mean, all the, all the programs and platforms are struggling with this volume.
And so I kind of thought it would be neat if for our program managers who are listening and also platforms, I just wanted to bring one like kind of key piece of advice that I thought of in the most recent have meeting.
Um, it's nothing confidential or anything, but I just think that for companies that are struggling.
And for the fact that when platforms are struggling, if they basically gave this option to all of their programs, it would reduce the total traffic and total volume by like, you know, 50% or something crazy and allow everyone to catch up and then allow us to get back to have faster triage and faster bounty times.
Right.
Cause it's hard on everybody.
They feel behind on their SLAs.
We feel frustrated because they're taking forever to get stuff triage and to get bound and payouts out.
And then when you're waiting a long time in triage, sometimes the bug gets fixed.
And then that's really frustrating, hard to handle happening.
So, so I think that my, um, I just have this, like one little concise pitch I think would be really beneficial if you're a program manager or you're a CSM for a platform and you've got companies that are struggling, just offer them like this, like a plate, this like platter of options.
It's like, here's the things you can do and you should do some of them.
You could take your program private.
Well, you know, I don't love that idea, but this is just one option you could require.
You could require videos for, for, for, and we talked about this even like, you know, you could require videos for your, um, reports.
You could require higher signal.
So you could bump up your signal requirements.
I've never seen a company like bump it to like five or six on hacker one, but that'd be kind of interesting to see what happens.
You could allow trusted or verified people only.
So you kind of like, you know, disallow people who are not like verified in the system.
Um, and actually I just saw James Kettle is talking about our episode.
He said he really liked it.
The most recent episode, um, in discord.
And he said that what they've done for the Porsche wigger program is they've left highs and criticals at the same payouts, but they've reduced the bounties on their lows and mediums.
And we're seeing that a lot actually.
I think that's kind of reasonable.
Um, just because like, those are going to be harder to get to these days.
Um, some of the outcome output that I've learned from the hacker advisory board meetings is that there's kind of like an exponential curve of like unfixed bugs.
It's not fully exponential yet, but it looks like an exponential curve with the number of like outstanding reports across all, across all, um, programs.
And so what that tells me is they're having a hard time fixing it as fast as the bugs are coming in.
Right.
And I think we knew that would be the case this year as everyone's scaling up their hackbots, like as all of this low and medium hanging fruit gets found, the developers of these companies can't keep up.
And so I think that one way you can, you know, kind of cut down on the lows and mediums and also save on your security budget, because you might be like be literally running out and like struggling to get back more, um, finances to cover those is to either, you know, stop paying loads and mediums, which I don't love or reduce the payout.
Or reduce the payouts on the lows and mediums.
But I think Justin, you would definitely say try to protect your highs and crits because one, that's where the real impact is.
And two that, like, if you, if you reduce those one, you might not actually get hackers looking at your program anymore, because right now what I'm deciding to point my hackbot out is really at like, what is the highest payout I can get?
Like, what is the critical payouts?
So you're not going to get, you know, as protected, but also it's just like what matters to us.
So, yeah, yeah, I certainly think that we are in a different environment than we were in when I said, you know, praising the low and mediums, right?
I, you know, you're worried.
I'm worried for the whole ecosystem in general.
Yeah.
And I think that if they have to, you know, make some changes for lows and mediums, I understand that.
I'm finding a lot more highs and crits than I used to because of the hackbots.
Right.
Um, so I'll, I'll say that would I like to see it?
Absolutely not.
I would love to not see it, you know, uh, but because the acquats are also freaking good at finding mediums, you know, lows and mediums.
Um, I like your signal idea.
I'm looking at the leaderboard right now.
There are a lot of people in the top 100 that have, you know, below five signal.
Really?
I was kind of thinking five would be the cutoff.
The top 30 pretty much all have above, um, six signal.
I think ironically today is new.
I think is that like 5.3, nine, three or something like that.
Um, but you know, you could make your cutoff at like five, right.
You know, or something like that.
And that might help that will cut out some of the top hackers, which is crazy.
Um, but that's a part of the game, I guess.
Yeah.
Um, the one that I liked the most though is, uh, requiring video PC.
And, uh, or paying for submission.
Yeah.
Those are the ones that I like.
I think that those are great ideas and that would really boost the ecosystem a lot.
They implemented that on hack and proof.
I think it's just unlikely with the speed and pace of development, a hacker one and bug crowd that that would actually come out.
Um, I think it would be more likely they could convert like your signal or rep into like points you can spend.
And then if you run out of those, um, you get it.
You get it.
That's a good idea.
The other idea I had, Justin, I think you might really like this one because it doesn't penalize people like you and I.
Mm-hmm.
Is that, um, you could do a, a system where you get a bounty reducer percentage based on the amount of slop you have.
Or, or, or maybe you even get an increase if you, if you never post any slop.
So like if you start getting an A's, you get like a 10% bounty reduction, then a 20%, then a 30%, right?
And so it doesn't ever leave us in the situation where a person finds a bug and they can't submit it.
Because I think that that often leads to like bad public disclosures because they get mad and they're posting on Twitter and it's like, because their signal's too low.
Right.
It's like, well, what am I supposed to do?
How am I supposed to report it?
And like, you end up in these situations where it's that.
But I think that if the, if it's like, no, you can still submit it, but you're going to get a 50% bounty because you've been like wasting so much of our time.
It kind of makes the balance between time and effort for them to triage more reasonable.
That doesn't really decrease the triage burden though.
Like, I mean, it will over the longterm, but it doesn't stop the bleeding right now.
I feel like we're in a tourniquet situation here.
Oh really?
Where we need to like stop the bleeding right now, like you said.
And that's why I think hack and proofs dollar to submit a bug.
No one gives a shit about a dollar.
Right.
You know, if you're submitting a bug.
If you are submitting a real bug that has the potential to be paid thousands of dollars, you don't give a shit about it.
Well, they did notice that $2, $1 and $2 penalties don't reduce slop.
But when you get to five, it does reduce it.
Yeah.
So there was, there was cutoff points.
They did it $2 and it didn't stop slop at all.
At five, it stopped like 80% and by like $8 or $10, it stopped like a hundred percent.
So they should just do $5 is my point.
And it's refunded, right?
Yeah.
And it's refunded if it's a valid bug.
But then also you could even scale it based on a region of the world.
And then of course there's like VPN issues and all that.
But I do think that like, you know, $5 for a new hacker, they might struggle or not really want to or something.
But yeah, it's still five bucks.
Yeah, I think that I think that we would maybe see grants or something like that in that situation where, you know, if you get a vouch or something like that from somebody in the system.
Yeah, that you are going to not submit shit, then, you know, you get a voucher for like 50 bucks in free submissions or something like that.
I think that'd be pretty interesting.
I like it.
It doesn't, it doesn't affect, it doesn't affect the real players.
It will affect new, new players.
But good luck new players moving into the system.
I mean, there really is a lot of benefits to you right now with Claude and you can, you know, get a lot of things explained to you.
But there's also a lot of competition.
So it's, it's an interesting, interesting time.
All right.
Am I up next?
Well, actually, just one more thing on that.
I think it's actually a really key insight.
I work with a third world hacker as like somebody that I sometimes collaborate with.
And he will, we've made like, you know, tens of thousands of dollars together over just this, just this year.
And, and the way that he brings a lot of value to me and that we end up collaborating.
So in such a beneficial way is because he'll be like, Hey, I'm in this program.
I'm looking at this thing.
It's kind of interesting.
Will you put your Claude on it?
And I, it's basically no time to me.
I'm like, yeah, sure.
Here, Claude, take a look at this.
And then it finds something.
And then we go back and we find stuff and he has Claude code too.
But I think that just like the, my set, my system or my setup for some reason, we'll find stuff that his doesn't.
And so if you are, if you are a new person, I think reaching out to like some top hackers and being like, Hey, you know, I've been looking at this thing.
Cause they even top hackers with a lot of hack bots that are scaling.
We still can't look at everything all the time.
So if you find something interesting, a way that you can make sure you get a good, or like you, you make sure you're not leaving stuff hanging is by reaching out to some top hunters that, you know, and being like, Hey, I found this lead.
Do you mind to like, take a look?
Yeah.
That's that makes sense.
Um, I don't know that I can deal with any more influx of that.
Uh, maybe send it, send it to Joseph.
I don't know.
I'm pretty busy too, but yeah, there's plenty of people in the, in the critical thinkers chat that are like very highly talented.
Just look for a collaborator.
Yeah, absolutely.
Um, all right.
Speaking of, uh, you know, collaborators of yours, um, we have, uh, an article by XSS doctor, um, with XSS doc and.
Um, Monke's new startup star strike.
Um, they are, they released an article called achieving deterministic prompt injection through client side feedback loops.
And I wanted to run you guys through this really quick.
Cause I think this shows the docs mastery of client side concepts, um, and really beautiful weaponization of them.
Okay.
Yeah.
So the TLDR of this article is that there is a, um, Q parameter on a chat bot, which allows you to do prompt
injection 20, 30, 50% of the time that will result in XSS.
That is not great for triage because what's going to happen is they're going to click it and it's not going to work.
And then they're going to NMI you and it's going to waste your life.
And it's not a great exploit, right?
You know, it, it, sometimes, uh, people will decrease the bounty for non-deterministic AI exploits.
Mm-hmm .
So what they cover in this, um, in this article is how to make it more deterministic.
Um, there's also a post message based race condition in here, which utilizes the technique that we discussed on, uh, the, um, hack along that we did on Adobe not too long ago in the critical thinking discord, where you pop up a small window and keep that in the front of the victim window.
Uh, to make sure that you were that both of the victim window and the attacker window are in focus or in view, which limits the, uh, rate limiting on post messages being sent cross origin.
So that's a good technique, uh, that I wanted to pass off to you guys.
Uh, but the whole setup here is, um, doc pops open a new window.
This is the attacker's window.
And in the background, he multiple times sends the prompt injection, sends it once, waits 10 seconds.
If he does not get a call back from the XSS firing, he will re inject the prompt again.
And then wait another 10 seconds.
Doesn't get a call back.
Send it again.
Right.
And so 30 seconds of sitting on the page, you have, you know, a massive chance of getting this exploit to actually work.
Okay.
So cool.
Um, very cool client side feedback loops.
Really good idea.
Great way to increase the, um, integrity of your exploits, whether it be a prompt injection related stuff or race conditions or both like, you know,
the situation is, um, I, I did want to mention one little bit here, uh, a modification that I had to this article.
Um, he solves a problem here and maybe he has a good reason for doing this.
I don't know, but he solves a problem here by, uh, of the victim, uh, I frame that is receiving the race condition.
Uh, he solves that not having a reference to the attacker's window by making the parent, the opener of the attacker's window as well.
So it's a mutual opener situation.
So the attacker's window is an opener of the victim window and the victim window is an opener of the attacker's window.
Um, this is possible.
You can read it, how to, how to do it in the article.
Um, he says, the reason for that is that the victim had no, uh, window reference to the attacker page.
Um, however, the attacker had a reference to the victim page.
Um, and my solution to this would have been a little bit different.
My solution would have been to just use the post message event source.
So whenever you send a post message to an iframe, um, there will be an event object that gets passed into the post message handler.
And that event object has a dot source, uh, attribute.
That source is a window reference to the frame that created the post message that is being sent.
So I would have.
So that statement's actually wrong.
It's not that there's no reference.
It's just that.
Well, yeah, it will at this current time, it doesn't have a reference, but as soon as you send a post message in, in trigger the XSS, if you send another post message, then, uh, you can register an event handler to snag that post message and then, uh, log the event source and then shoot back out to the attacker's page.
Um, that's how I would have solved the problem.
Uh, just wanted to show that out there.
But I think this trick of having mutual, um, opener, uh, is also a really cool trick, uh, for you guys to know as well.
And it's really beautifully displayed here on their blog with, um, you know, a graph of this whole attack.
So great work by, um, XSS doc and Monke at starlight or starstrike.ai.
Yeah.
Good work.
All right.
We are low getting lower on time, but we're still doing fine.
I just wanted to mention to everyone, um, GPT five or sorry, five, five, GPT five, five.
So I've got two, uh, links I'm going to show.
Um, well actually one can we talk about slash goal, bro.
So is that as OP as it sounds?
It's so OP.
It's the exact solution that you wanted to run overnight.
You just give it a goal of like find five crits.
And then even if it finds two crits, it'll just keep going until like, it literally will just work until it reaches its success condition.
And it's so good.
Like to me, it almost, I hate this, but it's not existing cloud code.
Great question.
But it, it, uh, to me, it's like the final cheat code that makes this the barrier to entry to this basically zero.
So let me tell you why I was finally convinced to buy a codex, a sub and let me tell you how it went.
So I'm going to share my screen on this LinkedIn post.
There's one of these that I agree with.
Close your DMs first.
Yeah.
Uh, so actually that's true.
I always do that on X.
I always show my DMs and they have to scrub it.
So this is a very confusing chart.
And I also think it may have been cherry picked, but it still was enough to convince me.
So this says GPT five, five delivers the best for once.
We've seen to date for listeners.
I'm sorry, this is confusing, but there's basically two lines.
There's a white line, which is white box.
And it compares GPT five, Gemini three, Opus four, five, five, two, and Opus four, six.
I don't know why they didn't keep the white line going for the latest models.
But anyways, because like we have no, we have no idea on this white line, how Opus four, seven or GPT five, five do.
But the point is that when it comes to white box testing, the cloud models are better.
You can just tell by Opus four, six having a huge increase here.
Now I will say the Y acts on this is really dumb.
It's vulnerabilities found before first miss.
What do they mean by miss?
What do they miss?
Does that mean like before it didn't find a bug or, or that means it submitted a false positive.
So they picked a really obnoxious Y axis.
But anyways, this black box line is what convinced me.
So they have a dotted black box line.
So this is like, you know, again, it's just like the tracking of the vulnerabilities found
before miss across Opus four, five, all the way through Opus four, seven, and then GPT five, five.
And when you look here at Opus four, six, it's like, and also why is this not on the, like, how can you have, how can you have less than one vulnerability?
Is this like a 4.9?
No, no, that's not a big deal.
I mean, I'm not a big deal.
I'm not a big deal.
I think that statement is definitely true.
If you assume he's talking about like GPT 5-4 or GPT 5-3 or other companies, I don't think
it is better than 4-6 or 4-7 with code, like with white source white box code.
I can't imagine.
But in general, so anyways, this convinced me to try it.
Justin, within the first 30 minutes, it found three P1s of me running GPT.
No, I'm not kidding at all.
Now I will say it did have a little bit of advantage.
It was a fresh invite program on BookRoute.
It was like a new program that just dropped.
So, you know, take that with a grain of salt.
But still, that was faster and more efficient than what I had seen for Opus.
Now, for anyone wanting to try it, here's all I did.
I symlinked my CloudMD to AgentMD from .Cloud to .Codex folder.
Then I just had CloudCode symlink all of the folders in the skills folder to the codex skills
folder and then just ran it.
I got, and I am cyber approved or whatever, but I got no rejections.
I used slash gold to run this overnight.
It found like lots of other bugs.
My intuition is that it's like 10 or 20% better than 4.7 and 4.6 at black box testing.
And Justin, I like didn't run out of tokens.
I had one slash gold that ran for 14 hours.
And then when I checked, I'd only use like 15% of my weekly usage stats, meaning that I could, that was like 1 30th of the monthly stats for the $200 a month.
Anyways, it's wildly effective.
I think people should basically be building their systems to be usable by both CloudCode and Codex.
And I think that, you know, in the past I was like, no, CloudCode, CloudCode, CloudCode.
Now I think it's totally reasonable to use either system and you'll be highly successful.
Dang, dude.
That's crazy.
I will say also, you know, with just 4.6, I also had a target on Bug Crowd this past week that is a fresh, fresh program.
So I wonder if, I wonder if we're going to dupe, hopefully not.
No, it's not.
Okay.
Yeah.
You can bleep that Richard.
Yes, please.
Yeah.
Okay.
So we're good.
But I literally, I was sitting here with my friends, right?
And we're like, let's just kick this off.
Let's see how it goes.
I kid you not within 15 minutes, it had an, a, like a JWT takeover.
JWT forging bypass, bro.
You know, I need to actually, I need to audit your JWT skill if you don't mind.
Yeah.
I got you.
I was saying that as a joke, cause I want to steal it.
Well, dude, you shared me so much.
I DM you all the time.
I'm like, tell me exactly how you do this.
Oh, you did do that yesterday.
Actually, when you did that yesterday, I was like, he's really sussing me out here.
I'm sussing you out.
Well, I'm also taking a different approach though.
So we can compare and contrast.
So the question I asked you yesterday, I did it different than you and JD.
So, um, we'll, we'll, we'll compare notes on that a different time.
Um, all right.
I've got one last, uh, write up.
This one is super sick.
Uh, save the best for last in my opinion here.
Um, freaking love.
Uriotak dude.
He's such a good hacker.
Uh, and anytime I read anything by him, uh, I am floored.
Um, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm,
I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm
on their blog, and it is remote code execution on Google Cloud with a single directory deletion, and this is on Google Cloud's Looker.
So Looker is a business intelligence platform. I've actually seen other bugs in this, so probably a good place to hunt.
He is able to get a self-hosted version so he can reverse engineer it, and he's looking at how all of this stuff works here in Ruby.
And the TLDR of the situation is he finds a way to delete an arbitrary directory from within his own repository via a, you know, confusion in the validate path name function for deleting the directory.
Yeah.
And he's able to use that to delete the .git repo for one of his projects that he's uploaded.
And then he says something that just freaking blew my mind and that everybody here should be paying very, very, very close attention to, okay?
Since it is possible to trick git into using forged git configurations if the .git directory is corrupt or deleted, the validate namedir method checks the directory to be deleted includes .git and raises an error if it does, okay?
So you're not supposed to be able to delete the .git directory.
Interesting.
And then he just kind of slips it in there.
Since it is possible to trick git into forging, as everybody knows, it's possible to trick git into using forged git configurations if the .git directory is corrupted or deleted, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
I went back and I was like, wait, what?
So if I can delete the .git repo from my, or the .git folder from my repository folder.
Yeah.
And you run a git command inside that folder, you can get rc.
This is essentially what this reduces to.
Wow.
Crazy.
Do you know how many coding, like AI coding sandbox features we've tested that that might be relevant to?
Yeah, dude.
A ton.
And so essentially, he explains the reason for this.
If the git directory is deleted, the next git command executed against this repository will fail to find the git directory and it will look for git configurations in the work tree directory instead.
Wow.
Therefore, if the work tree contains the files that resemble the contents of a .git, git assumes that you are in, let me, where is it?
No, are you kidding?
Yeah.
Git assumes that you are in the .git directory.
And we'll just load these files straight from the root of the work tree.
So let me just explain how this works.
So what's the folder you want to put it in?
Tell me, I need the juice right now, Justin.
Yeah, dude.
I mean, look at this graph that's on the screen.
Yeah.
Look at this graph that's on the screen.
You can put it in any of the, oh, you just put it, you just put it straight in it.
It thinks it's already inside .git.
Right.
So literally it thinks it's already inside .git.
So they're running a git command from the root directory of the repository.
Typically it says, okay, let me look at the .git, you know, folder, you know, if it's not there, oh shit, I guess we're inside the .git repo already.
So it just tries to read config.
Right.
And then treats it as .git slash config.
So this is the whole situation, right?
You guys can't, we can't upload, you know, malicious .git folders to git, right?
That's the, you know, that's where a lot of security in all of these systems relies on.
The .git repo is sacred, right?
And if I can check that to make sure there aren't hooks or whatever, you know, we're all good.
Right.
But then if you can delete that .git repo, it'll just treat the config file that's in the root of your repo as the git config.
And you can register hooks and then you're set.
Dude, we've got a week.
Can we go look for this in and and as soon as this calls over.
We're late.
I think this thing shipped in March.
Yeah, March.
But I mean, the number of people that saw this and then drew the same conclusion to us is probably pretty low.
I mean, people just read their eyes glaze over.
This is good stuff.
Anyway.
Honestly, is this a vulnerability in git?
No.
Are you sure?
No, no.
There's some code branch inside git inside git code that is saying if .git is not there, look in the current directory.
And I think that that is probably a vulnerability.
I think it should always make sure it's in a .git.
I don't know, man.
Maybe I'm misunderstanding it, but that seems like the way that git is just going to work.
I can definitely see the GitHub team being like, nah, bro.
Like, this is how it works, you know?
Yeah.
So anyway, then it's trivial.
Okay.
No, I'm sorry.
It's not trivial from there.
Let me also give another shout out to AudioTex Genius.
So now he's got the config file in there, right?
And so let me explain.
The way he got the directory to delete was actually not deleting the git directory at all.
He deleted the entire repository directory, right?
The entire one, including his own config files, right?
But the way that the delete recursive works in Ruby, you know, it will recursively go in and delete all the files.
Yeah.
So he created a folder that's massive, that has a ton of files in it, right?
That's going to take the delete after the .git and before his config, right?
So what will happen is this.
He'll say, delete the whole repository folder.
And he'll say, okay, great.
Going to recursively delete.
It goes in there, deletes the .git, right?
So now we're in a vulnerable state.
Then it finds AudioTex massive folder, you know?
Yes.
And then 1500 million, you know, files, uh, you know, nested within that.
It goes deep.
It's deleting files.
It's taken forever.
In the meantime, AudioTex is hitting another endpoint that runs git status on that same folder in the middle of deletion.
Oh my gosh.
Triggers the config for, um, you know,
He's literally an AI, Justin.
Dude.
Triggers the FS monitor hook and then runs arbitrary commands on the Google prod.
He's a robot server.
Freaking beautiful, man.
That is crazy.
I love it.
And he explains the nuance of like the XF4 file system and how, um, the Ruby file utils RM-RF, uh, you know, recursively delete stuff.
It was beautifully done.
But the concept is that, and it was just chef's kiss, dude.
Yeah.
That's insane.
And then he explains even the full privilege escalation, um, inside of a Google Kubernetes cluster as well.
Um, cause he's able to check the service account in slash RR slash run slash secrets slash Kubernetes IO slash service account.
And then he's able to check the service account and find some excessive permissions that they're able to update secrets for all the other Kubernetes clusters as well, which results in full privilege escalation.
So.
Wow.
Yeah.
That is so sick.
You're right.
You did save the best for last.
That was a freaking beautiful bug, right?
The race condition, the get like confusion.
Yeah.
Dude.
It's just beautiful.
Yeah.
Oh man.
Shout out to Ryo Tuck in flat.
Um, all right.
You got anything else or is that a wrap right on time?
Let me check the notes.
No, it looks good.
I'm done.
Yeah.
All right, dude.
That's the pod then.
Peace.
Thanks.
And that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking.
Thanks so much for watching to the end y'all.
If you want more critical thinking content, uh, or if you want to support the show, head
over to ctbb.show slash discord.
You can hop in the community.
There's lots of great high level hacking discussion happening there on top of masterclasses, hack
alongs, exclusive content, and a full-time hunters guild.
If you're a full-time hunter, it's a great time.
Trust me.
I'll see you there.